alors nous avons travaillé sur ces
questions de comment décarboner la
mobilité routière et avons construit sur
ce terrain un plan en 5 points le
premier point c'est le développement des
infrastructures et des services de
mobilité partagée pour mieux utiliser la
route qui est une infrastructure
existante et qui mérite d'être optimisé
il s'agit de développer le covoiturage
l'épaule d'échanges multimodo les
carexpress sur autoroute ou les voies
réservées il s'agit ensuite d'accueillir
des motorisations décarbonées dont
notamment pour les VL se doter d'un
réseau de bornes de recharge ultra
rapide suffisant pour accueillir une
flotte ou la pénétration du véhicule
électrique est exponentielle je rappelle
qu'en 2022 14% des véhicules vendus
étaient électriques et c'est ce qui
représente une part super à la part des
véhicules diesel vendus le troisième axe
c'est de faire de l'autoroute un centre
de production d'énergie
renouvelables et je voudrais de ce point
de vue dire ma déception sur la loi de
d'accélération récemment promulguée elle
fera gagner au mieux six mois sur les
quatre ans et demi qu'il faut en France
pour conduire construire un parc
photovoltaïque là où il ne faut que deux
ans en Allemagne et alors que il faut 6
mois de travaux pour déployer des
panneaux photovoltaïques qu'il me semble
qu'on aurait gagné à les déployer
rapidement et de façon volontariste sur
l'ensemble des axes de transport
linéaire je pense aux délaissé
ferroviaire ou au délaissé autoroutier
le quatrième max c'est les efforts de
fluidification du trafic par
l'innovation et la promotion à la fois
des véhicules autonomes et connectés et
puis par le passage en flux libre au
péage et le cinquième point qui est très
important c'est les efforts
d'investissement pour améliorer la
résilience des infrastructures dans les
milieux naturel il s'agit à la fois des
forces sur la biodiversité mais surtout
de la résistance des ouvrages aux
incendies ou aux inondations dont on
voit la multiplication dans la période
récente nous estimons que l'effort
d'investissement sur le réseau
actuellement considéré représenterait
environ 60 milliards c'est un effort
important mais qui ne représente qu'un
tiers de la valeur du réseau concédé
dans les contes de l'État et finalement
il nous faut faire un effort
d'investissement au 21e siècle trois
fois moins important pour décarboner que
celui qu'on fait les générations
précédentes pour construire le réseau
actuel